SEARS.COM.
COME FIND OUT MORE ABOUT ME.
AWESOME.
>> Rachel: WELL SOME MEMBERS OF
THE LEFT ARE DOUBLING DOWN ON
THEIR WOKE IDEOLOGIES OTHERS SEE
THE VIRGINIA RACE AS A RECKONING
FOR THE POLICY.
>> STUPID WOKENESS.
ALL RIGHT?
JUST DON'T LOOK AT VIRGINIA AND
NEW JERSEY.
LOOK AT LONG ISLAND.
LOOK AT BUFFALO.
LOOK AT MINNEAPOLIS.
EVEN LOOK AT SEATTLE,
WASHINGTON.
I MEAN, THIS DEFUND THE POLICE
LUNACY, THIS TAKE ABRAHAM
LINCOLN'S NAME OFF THE SCHOOLS,
PEOPLE SEE THAT.
AND IT'S JUST REALLY HAS A
SUSPECT PROGRESSIVE EFFECT.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE NEED TO GO
AWOKE DETOX CENTER OR SOMETHING.
>> Rachel: JOINING ME NOW IS
GOLDEN, THE AUTHOR OF THE
UPCOMING BOOK.
>> JAMES CARVILLE DOES HAVE A
POINT.
WOKENESS IS PUTTING DEMOCRATS TO
SLEEP.
THEY THEIR ELECTORAL CHANCES
ANYWAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU HAVE A
RADICALISM THAT CAN'T BE HIDDEN
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ANYMORE.
AND YOU HAVE TODAY, JUST TODAY
AOC W CIALT WEPT ON THE LAUNCH
PAD THAT REASON THEY LOST TOO
MODERATE.
BY ALL MEANS PLEASE, GO EVEN
FURTHER TO THE LEFT AND LOSE
MORE ELECTIONS AND LET'S SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN 2022.
>> Rachel: WHAT IS THE LESSON
OFFICIALLY FOR NOT JUST FOR
DEMOCRATS BUT FOR REPUBLICANS
FROM LAST NIGHT?
>> WELL, THE LESSONS FOR
REPUBLICANS WELL, THEY WOULD BE
TAKING THE WRONG LESSON AWAY BY
THE WAY AS I HEARD SOME OF THE
PUNDITS SAY THAT THIS IS PROOF
THAT THEY SHOULD DISTANCE FROM
TRUMP THAT WAS THE TRUMP BASE
THAT CAME OUT.
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
THE SECOND LESSON THEY SHOULD
TAKE IS TO ON MYSTIC, BE A HAPPY
WARRIOR IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN VIRGINIA,
ESPECIALLY, YOU JUST HAD THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ON.
>> WE HAVE OPTIMISTIC.
>> WE HAVE POSITIVE THINKING.
THE GOVERNOR IS THE SAME WAY.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE PROMISE THAT
VIRGINIA HAD FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
HE TALKED ABOUT EDUCATING,
MAKING VIRGINIA A PLACE WANTED
TO LIVE NEVER GAVE IN TO THE
NEGATIVISM FROM THE LEFT THAT
CAN ONLY ENGAGE IN NAME-CALLING.
WHAT HE DID WAS OFFER OPTIMISTIC
VIEWPOINT FOR THE PEOPLE OF
VIRGINIA AND IT RESONATED.
HE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
CONCERNS OF PARENTS AND THESE
ARE REAL CONCERNS AND THAT
RESONATED.
WHAT DID HE DO WHEN HE CAME TO
DOWN, WHAT DID JOE BIDEN DO?
THEY DEMONIZED PARENTS.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
STAY OPTIMISTIC AND STAY O